hello everyone I am mayank and welcome
to this video on graph neural networks
by simply learn in this video we will
cover topics like what our graph is
moving forward and we'll see why it is
hard to analyze a graph after that we
will cover what graph neural networks
are after that we will look into types
of gnns gnns means graph neural networks
after covering all these topics we will
cover some advantages and disadvantages
of gnns and at the end we will see some
applications of the DNS so let me tell
you guys that we have regular updates on
multiple Technologies if you are a tech
geek on a continuous hand for the latest
technological Trends then consider
getting subscribed to our YouTube
channel and press that Bell icon to
never miss any update from Simply learn
so let's get started also accelerate
your career in Ai and ml with
copernences processor program in Ai and
machine learning gain expertise in
machine learning deep learning NLP
computer vision and the info enforcement
learning you will receive a procedure
certificate exclusive alumni membership
and ask me anything sessions by IBM with
three Capstone and 25 plus industry
projects using real data sets from
Twitter Uber and more you will gain
practical experience masterclasses by
Caltech faculty and IBM experts ensure
you the top-notch education simply
against job assist help you get noticed
by Leading companies this program covers
statistics python supervised and
unsupervised learning NLP and neural
network computer vision genes Keras
tensorflow and many more skills so
enroll now and unlock exciting Ai and ml
opportunities coastlink is mentioned in
the description box below so let's see
what is a graph so at the core of graph
neural network gnns is a fundamental
Concept in the computer science a graph
is a data structure comprising two
Essential Elements first is node or
vertices and the edges so in case where
there are directional relationship
between nodes that edges are considered
as a director okay it is known as the
directed graph on the other hand if
there are no directional dependencies
the ssrt does are undirected graph okay
so a graph G is defined as g equals to
ve where V represents set of nodes and
the E represents the edges connecting to
these nodes so moving forward let's see
why it is hard to analyze a graph so
graph data present many challenges for
the conventional machine learning
algorithm due to it its inherent
complexity so unlike simple data types
of these algorithms specialized in such
as images with fixed structure and the
sizes resembling grid graphs or
sequences like text and speech
representing line graphs graphs can be
far more intricate so graphs do not
conform to a fixed form and vary in size
and unorder nodes where each node can
have various neighbors this is dynamic
and irregular nature poses a significant
obstacle to traditional machine learning
tools so for the more exciting machine
learning algorithms are built on this
core assumption that instance are
dependent of the each other so let's
move forward and see what are graph
neural network so gnn's craft neural
networks are a category of deep learning
techniques specifically crafted for
analyzing data represent in graph
structures they serve as neural network
tailored to process graphs directly
offering a convenient approach and
Performing prediction at the node Edge
and the graph levels with gns it becomes
feasible to conduct challenging tasks
for conventional neural network CNN
allowing for more effective and
versatile analysis for graph structured
data so moving forward let's see types
of DNS graph neural network gnns are
neural network design explicitly to
process graph structure data offering a
versatile approach for Edge node and
graph level prediction so they can be
categorized into three main types first
one is decurrent graph neural network
this type of gnns incorporate recurrent
cells into its architecture enabling the
model to capture temporal dependency and
sequential patterns in the graph data
the second one is special conversational
Network so special CNN are inspired by
traditional CNN and operate on a node
local neighborhood they aggregate
information from neighboring nodes to
update a nodes representation and the
third one is spectral convolutional
neural network so spectral conventional
dnns operate in the spectral domain by
using egn values and the egn vectors of
the graph agency Matrix this allows them
to handle graph signals efficiency and
capture Global structure so at the core
of GNN slides the fundamental
institution that nodes in a graph are
defined by their connection and
Neighbors when visualizing this concept
it becomes apparent that removing all of
the neighbor's word lead to the node
losing all its information so after
covering types of gnns let's see
advantages and the disadvantages of
genus first we will see some advantages
so first one is handling complex data so
gnn's excel at processing complex and
irregular graph structure data which
cannot be easily represented using
traditional data structure like grids or
sequences the second one is capturing
local and Global Information gnns can
capture both local and Global
Information of nodes in a graph the
message passing mechanism enables nodes
to learn from their immediate neighbor
while considering higher level
structural pattern in the graph and the
third one is parameter sharing gnn's
share parameter across node in the same
layer reducing the model memory
footprint and making them more scalable
than fully connected architecture and
the fourth one is end-to-end learning
gnns can be trained to end-to-end
learning hierarchical representation and
feature embedding directly from the
graph today and data without relying on
the handcart feature and the last one is
transferability so gnns demonstrate
transfer learning capabilities models
pretend data on a graph can often be
fine-tuned or adapted to focus while on
related graph even with different size
of a structure and some disadvantages of
genes are first one is scalability so
training gnns on large labor can be
computationally expensive and memory
intensive due to the need of propagate
message between nodes and the second one
is limited generalization dnns May
struggle to generalize well on graphs
that significantly differ from the
training graph in the terms of structure
or destruction this limitation can be
problematic when dealing with dynamic or
evolving graphs and the third one is
interpretability so gns Black Box nature
can make them challenging to interrupt
and understand especially when making
critical decision in domains like
healthcare or finance and the fourth one
is over smoothing DNS may suffer from
over smoothing where nodes
representations become oversimilarly
after multiple layers of message
possible this can lead to a loss of
valuable information and reduce model
performance and the last one is handling
different graph sizes genus typically
expect graph with a fixed size during
training making it challenging to apply
them to graphs with varying node or Edge
counts graph pooling techniques are
often employed to address this issue but
it can still be a concern so in in
conclusion graph neural networks offer
powerful capabilities for handing
complex graph structured data and have
shown success in various applications
however there is scalability
generalization and adaptability to
different graph sizes remain active
areas of research and Improvement
understanding the advantages and the
disadvantages of GNN is crucial in
selecting the appropriate model for a
specific task and mitigating potential
challenges moving forward let's see
application of gnns the first one is
social network analysis genus can be
used to model and analyze social
networking making prediction on user
interaction influence propagation and
Community detection they help in
identify influential users
recommendation connection and
understanding the network Dynamics and
the second one is recommender system
gnns effectively build recommendation
engine that provide personal suggestion
based on user items interact Graphics
they can learn user preferences and item
characteristics to make accurate and
relevant recommendation and the third
one is traffic prediction gnns can be
used to analyze Transportation networks
such as Road Network and public
transportation system for predicting
traffic flow and congestion patterns and
optimizing routes and the fourth one is
computer Visions gnns are used in
computer vision's tasks involving
structured data such as image parsing
sync graph generation and object
relationship understanding and the fifth
one is financial fraud detection genance
can be employed to analyze financial
transaction graphs to identify fraud and
activities detect anomalies enhance
security measures so these applications
demonstrate the versatility and the
utility of genus in addressing complex
real world problem that involve graph
restructure data as research in the
field of progressive DNS are expected to
find even more application across
various domain so that's all we had for
you in this video we can call it our
Apna if you still have any question or
doubt let us know in the comment section
below and our team of experts will help
you add the list thank you so much for
being here today we'll see you next time
until then stay safe and keep learning
with simply learn staying ahead in your
career requires continuous learning and
upskilling whether you're a student
aiming to learn today's top skills or a
working professional looking to advance
your career we've got you covered
explore our impressive catalog of
certification programs in Cutting Edge
domains including data science cloud
computing cyber security AI machine
learning or digital marketing designed
in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations and
delivered by industry experts choose any
of our programs and set yourself on the
path to Career Success click the link in
the description to know more
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here